ich möchte jetzt aufgetaucht ja ab nein
was ich möchte jetzt noch nicht jetzt
noch nicht sterben
ja genau auch geld schlecht auf einmal
drücken
ja das ist eine konstant heftiger sound
jetzt neuerdings
ich meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge und
computer zusammen mit pommes hatte und
dumm gespielt
ich bin nicht dumm ist fertig übrigens
kommen diesmal auch mit auf das heißt
bei kommen könnte eine folge sehen
hier sind gerade menge leute bei uns
einfach aber einfach weil wir lange
penis haben zeche lohberg cool sind und
mit unschönen wollen ganz andere welt in
welche lobby die keine ahnung schlag
eine vor 19 19 nämlich heute nicht mehr
in welchem es etwas einfacher macht dich
hab 90 / was dann lass uns lieber in
mainz 1 1 5011 gleiche level wartet kurz
mit den leveln und ich würde mir und
fairground gehen also werde welche
welche erst gar nicht
temple of keine ahnung anwalt neuen kopf
nicht aktiv zog jetzt wie wo welche
locations 4888 allen acht okay okay ich
war ganz meinen sound mal ganz oben
alles geht schon los
olaf bock ich mal ganz genau an
und ich nehme an dass keiner von euch
beiden juroren nicht wir können
die urbanisierung ok geil da heißt ihr
wisst schon losgegangen
naja jetzt los das heißt wir müssen
jetzt einfach diesen hebel branding jaja
aber am anfang müssen bis ein bisschen
zurückhaltend
genau weil der halt noch wirklich stark
ist und wir noch schnell sterben können
ich habe alles lauter teil von diesen
jungen gerade an gemacht dann wird es
ein bisschen ross fisher und folgt das
vergessen es ist so schlimm muss man das
machen alte honda geil ich glaube ich
krieg die start von michaela fischer
machen dass sich aus liebe sterben als
laufe ich hab heute laufe ich hab den
chart jawoll
ja ich habe mich abgesehen ich hätte
mich sofort komme sofort kommen kommt
alles hinter mir ich glaub ich nicht gar
nicht mehr an
auf der linken seite da wo auch alle
anderen katharina gut nur einer komme
wenn du hast reale chance den jungen zu
töten
general ich muss das erst mal schaffen
wo ist gar nicht verstehen nicht was
sagt ihr
ich bin hier auf der leinwand der ist
hier beim des gameplays ihr buch ist
überall so abgeben da bedingt der
präsident im schwarzen dampf gesehen
hier ich bin gleich da ich bin ich
gleich geblieben ist ja hier im späten
handel schwächer aber ich hab' ich habe
ich und ein traktor auf afrika geht also
ist jetzt versteckt euch versteckt euch
gleich hier versteckt euch ja klar ich
bin so gut wie tot
das heißt wir müssen jetzt noch ein
chart hohen einfach und wo man auf
einladung der auftritt hast du das sehe
ich noch mal beim kompass und meinem
blitz der kompass sagt mir doch auch wo
der ist oder nicht
ach ich laufe einfach werden die gleiche
richtung okay ich weiß nicht wo ihr seid
einfach nur versucht zu überleben wo
bist du
der ist schon tot
nein na klar nachdem ich gestorben bin
stimmt auch nicht
die htc handy klingelte mein handy
klinik angehen es liegt irgendwann den
besten acht teams teil auftritt zu
klingen gebracht kann man auf dem kopf
trug brown wird ja kommentieren
doch nicht alle ach du auch hier ach du
hier komme ich dachte ja mögen gewährt
in hollywood was macht ihr denn gerade
ich dollar beinahe die alleinig die
karte verdammt egal
ihr habt keine chance beim hdd o'brien
quali ich gibt einen tipp versteckt sich
erst am anfang
und wenn ein weg gebracht ist dann
können wir töten ich trete ja direkt ich
schaffe das schaffst du nicht hast du
nicht in den scanner hier grade es geht
bei mir
werden auch alle allem eine runde als
vielleicht für die hunde taktik ist zb
wolf taktik die bvt hat genau den gibt's
nicht mit heute mal dies wirklich gut
eigentlich immer überlegt aber der
letzte klappe
ich möchte jetzt so richtig dass
aufgetaucht
der schaut ja ab nein blogspot com was
du bist schlecht ich steckte fest
vertäut ist tot
ja ist ja nächste runde direkt
aufeinander noch ich bin nicht behindert
viele habe 7777 bei mir das spielehandy
warum kann man jetzt auch in rom ein
jugendtreff daran bei mir das kind ich
habe keine persson das spiel hängen
geblieben ja dann machen wir heute
einmal eine hongkong hongkong bvb
spielen geblieben das ist das ganze
jetzt mal umkommen ungewiss
bei mir festspiele nicht aber auch was
mit kommen konnten
bei mir das spaß sie machen es langsam
ihr müsst also sonst könnte vielleicht
noch nicht wechseln weil ich heute auch
die lobby wechseln wenn ich eine
eingelöst hätte was wir jetzt auch ins
bett hängen wir jetzt marathon wieder
auf unseren links drauf weil wir sehen
noch eine minute zeit ja bei mir gab es
gerade vettel-finger
luca ruhig erstmal meinen penis raus
leute ich hatte dafür mega lektoren cool
was macht ihr bei den hier 30 sekunden
noch ne und gestehe ich lesen kann
ach so ein passendes conny ich habe
keine pässe monatlich pässe los angeles
passt da hast du kriegst du wirklich
also ich hab keine ahnung
ok
na ja nichts schlechtes
genau ich muss doch hier mal mich
beweisen aber diesmal spiele ich
ordentlich doch keine chance ehrlich ich
bin ich kann gut spielt ehrlich alles in
meiner ersten roten hier leider kommen
welche scheiße nein das passiert als man
ganz schnell wenn niemand die bomben
wirft uns laufend einen netten worte die
helfen jetzt das ist natürlich wenn
dahinter wir sind jetzt allerdings die
schadprogramme ist
typische fall getroffen mein gott ich
für explosion
das war mal irgendjemand granaten
geworfen
granat man kann granaten werfen als demo
allein charles weg gebracht worden
damit mehr schaden gekommen wo bist du
denn
ja ich weiß nicht wo ich bin ich kann
die karte nicht
scheiße mann ich klicke einfach nur
drauf los hier im wasser komme es wird
nichts mehr passiert etwas das wort das
wird was schon hier eine rot hat keine
chance ehrlichmann ich werde euch alle
vernichten der runden 1
was wollt ihr jetzt alle auf einem
haufen hier wir jetzt das fertig ich
glaube das wird nichts mehr so dass ein
getötet broccoli player der app auch
komme ich habe nur noch ein halbes herz
und angeführt hinweis nach spahns ich
keine ahnung welche töten soll
es stimmt dass wenn man eine gute idee
nein ich bringe dich hast du nicht
geschafft oder nicht
ich werde um gespielt aufhalten glaube
ich helfe dir halte mich nicht auf ich
bin richtig lieb doch haltet in der
mitte beschreibt das skoda sie
beschützen müssen bitte schützt mich
dritte lauf doch wirklich töten wollte
beschützt sich mit simon und mein gott
jetzt ein kurzes from beschützt mich
beschützt mich ich bin schwarz
warum schützt mich du bist du denn du
hast nicht geschafft ich hab' ich weg
gebracht mit der weißen elster dame weiß
ich wie tot
ich bin tot ja so gut wie tot ist das
ist aber auch immer kaffee wenn man die
youtuber spielt die auch noch etwas
ahnung haben was sie hier machen ja ich
zum beispiel wollte da gerade keine
ausnahme machen
ich bin perfekt in diesem spiel und ich
werde auch kommen
oder er wird von einem blitz getroffen
beim schweißen
da ist es so das denn
da kommt ja ich komme ja komm ich komme
man hier muss man die hoch kommen was
die kaputte kaiser leiser hier kommen
hoch was die caputs vorab man jetzt bist
du dran komme hier richtig konzentriert
dabei halte ich sehe euch nicht wo seid
ihr dann gespielt jetzt schlägt eine
stunde
helft mir abhängt eure stunde
helft mir helft mir helft mir helft mir
am anfang ja ich bin noch nie so schöne
runde aus
ich bin langsam gebracht ich bin so gut
aber ich hab mich gebessert auf jeden
fall voll adrenalin gewinnen
aufgepumpt über minecraft spielen
scheiße unter die schau dich so recht
dürfen ganz netter ich hätte ich noch
nicht getötet ich hoffe nicht man ja auf
jeden fall leute wenn euch die dritte
folge der ungar peter fischer gefallen
als dann schreibt doch einfach mal in
die kommentare und konnten mit unserer
und kommen und kommen damit unserem
schönen special gast hier galladé
natürlich auch in der video beschreibung
zu finden und eine runde hochgeladen und
ja ganz nett grunde aus der sicht des
jungen schauen wollte auf jeden fall mal
schauen wer die sicht mit facetime aus
meiner sicht wo ich einfach nur um show
und wir die hosen scheißen wollte mir
vorbei aber es ist heute am besten bald
vorbei und bei mir einfach vorbeigucken
wenn die totale versehen aber ich meine
fans habe ich auch ne
damit kann ich ja auch anbieten aber ich
hab die heftigsten feld okay das stimmt
macht euch einfach alle drei sachen
gleichzeitig andern leichter dann könnt
ihr euch das alles auf einmal angucken
das ist ja genau auch geld schlecht
alles auf einmal drücken
ja das ist eine konnte und heftiger
sound jetzt neuerdings dadurch sagen bis
morgen gibt es die nächste und pvp show
und damit mit einer weiter modi in die
kommentare schreiben und damit die halbe
sachen durchgespielt schreibt einfach
eure vorschläge kontakt mit